hi guys in this video we're going to
give you an overview of keto and in a
minute fasting okay from A to Z let's
take a look at all the things that
happen and all the barriers that you
might run into I mainly created this for
new people just so they could see
everything together I know it looks
complex but let's just kind of go
through it okay so here you are you're
having breakfast lunch and dinner don't
forget about the snack snack snack
s'right that's an average person you're
just pretty much grazing the whole day
you got belly fat fatigue memory
problems lack of focus you're craving
high blood pressure anxiety depression
and diabetes but other than that you're
doing pretty good so what is the common
denominator of all these high levels of
insulin okay you have insulin resistance
which is causing high levels of insulin
that's what's creating all these
symptoms so these symptoms are the tip
of the iceberg this is the iceberg okay
so we have to fix this the way we do it
is through keto because keto is gonna
lower the carb and it's going to reduce
the insulin all right intermittent
fasting works because you're gonna eat
less frequent not the amount but less
frequent because every time you eat you
trigger insulin so the combination works
really good to lower insulin okay so
you're gonna start it right okay so now
between day 1 and day 3 you may go
through a little transition period which
you're gonna feel some symptoms of the
low blood sugar and that would be
lightheadedness hunger and cravings
maybe a headache
you have to realize it's temporary and
if you give up right here you're gonna
lose the benefits of all the great
things down the road so just realize
it's gonna happen and just hang in there
but you can actually increase potassium
and B vitamins to make it even smoother
I recommend the electrolyte powder and
nutritional yeast tablets okay so for
this we're going to do three meals only
no snacks because we're transitioning
from sugar to fat so when you make the
transition you're gonna make new
cellular machines that run on fat and
not sugar anymore okay that's key to
adaptation now the way to do that is
you're going to go from one meal to the
next you're going to have to
some fad to satisfy you so you're not
hungry
so the fat is the thing that you need to
adjust so you have just the right amount
so it's not too much where you feeling
bloated and right shoulder pain and a
headache and you have just enough to go
from this meal to this meal when you're
satisfied okay so you're gonna play
around with that and adjust that I'm
talking about brie cheese nuts pecans
are good walnuts are good eggs are good
avocado is good any of those fats are
really healthy and if you were to do a
hamburger for example which has twice as
much fat as protein versus a steak which
is twice as much protein versus fat
you'd be better off with the hamburger
because the fat helps you go from one
meal to the next all right so make sure
you have enough greens whether it's
salad or vegetables because we want to
start increasing potassium very
important you need 4700 milligrams of
potassium that's between seven and ten
cups of salad that's a nutrient-dense
food to allow the hunger to go away
because your body is finally going to be
satisfied of nutrients okay so you're
not eating these empty calories so but
primarily you're gonna get a lot of
potassium to really help reverse this
insulin resistance problem now you may
experience constipation for example in
which you might need to even add more
potassium or it could be the vegetables
that you're consuming you're not used to
like kale for example if you're having
too much kale that can bind you up if
that's the case switch the vegetable but
let's say you have keto fatigue and
you're tired that usually means low salt
so add some more sea salt and by the way
when you're doing a ketogenic diet you
need about one teaspoon of sea salt
every single day compared over here you
need about 1/4 of a teaspoon okay so we
need more sea salt not table salt to
actually prevent fatigue and help your
body with the electrolyte sodium and
chloride all right so we're gonna do
this for a while we're gonna get used to
it now we're going to slowly graduate to
two meals per day the way we're gonna do
that is we're going to take our
breakfast and we're going to start to
push it forward in other words when you
wake up in the morning
ask yourself am i hungry no good go
longer keep going longer and longer and
longer because if you do this right you
wake up at night you've been fasting all
night and now you're not hungry the
morning push it further and further and
further until you're at the lunch we
have no more breakfast and you're at 2
meals per day so that's how we want to
graduate slowly all right so don't eat
if you're not hungry
now at this point a lot of people
mention oh my gosh I was losing weight
on this and I stopped losing weight you
know what's happening well you don't
want to go by your weight why because a
lot of people that do this when you
measure them they are loaded with fat
and they have low muscle density they
don't have a lot of muscles anymore
they're basically have atrophy and they
think it's just all fat but it's atrophy
so you're gonna start growing more
muscle and all this protein is now
retaining in the body it's a little
heavier and that's why you're not losing
weight because muscle weighs more than
fat ok the best indicator for success is
your weight circumference ok so measure
your waist and that should be shrinking
if you're doing this correctly alright
now sometimes you might experience high
levels of something called uric acid you
might start noticing a gout symptom it
might not happen but if it does that is
normal in this transition phase or you
might if you're susceptible to getting a
kidney stone you might notice a little
pain in your lower back that's because
the higher levels of uric acid so you
just want to make sure that you're
consuming enough lemon juice or lemon in
your water or actual lemons ok lemon is
a great thing to help flush that out and
counter the effects of stones gout and
this acid okay so I recommend that and
also apple cider vinegar will also help
this as well
tablespoon in some water drink it with
your meals with a lemon and you're good
to go a couple of things will happen you
might consume food a little too much
because you're like going to two meals
and you're gonna you're afraid you're so
used to so many meals you're like oh my
gosh am I gonna be hungry so you stuff
yourself right well you just have to
make sure that you learn from that and
adjust the food because you you probably
don't need the stuff yourself I know
it's
hard to believe you might actually cheat
on this program somewhere and you might
find that the next day you're like way
more hungry than you were yesterday and
you're craving carbs okay because you
just bumped yourself out of this whole
ketosis just stick with the program get
back on the wagon and continue but if
you consume the wrong foods here
your blood sugar will be off then the
next day you're going to notice like wow
now I'm like really hungry
that's what that's all about one thing
to note is if you're doing two meals
make sure you're not doing low calories
make sure they're nutrient dense a
little bit more food so you're actually
satisfied and you're going to do three
to six ounces of protein unlimited
vegetables and the rest was fat now
right about here your friend calls you
and she says oh you're doing that keto
program did you realize that it destroys
the thyroid it's gonna make your thyroid
slow right well let me just explain the
facts on that so number one we're not
doing a low-calorie diet we're eating
less but we're keeping our calories high
the second thing you need to know is
that as your body becomes more efficient
the fuel is a more efficient fuel the
need for thyroid hormones are less so
you're not gonna need as much thyroid
hormones so if it goes down a little bit
this is completely normal
you're not losing your hair you're not
having other issues it's totally fine
especially if it's within the normal
range but your thyroid does not have to
work as hard when you're doing
intermittent fasting in keto all right
another thing is you might end up at the
doctor to get your annual checkup and
find that your cholesterol is high
before you freak out and start going on
a statin drug realize fat is composed of
triglycerides and cholesterol so guess
what when you release the fat your
cholesterol has to come out it has to go
through the blood it may increase
temporarily but the problem is most of
the cholesterol in your body is made by
your own body only ten percent comes
from the diet so if you eat more it
makes less if you eat less it makes
our body basically makes about 3,000
milligrams of cholesterol every single
day so it needs it for hormones it needs
it for the vision for the brain for the
nervous system and act as a band-aid to
help heal any type of lesions on the
arteries the real problem is this high
insulin that creates the inflammation in
the destruction of your arteries so if
your question is a little high this is a
temporary thing it's not an issue and
you want to keep your vegetables very
very high I recommend that you watch
some of my videos on LDL I've put some
links down below ok so from here to here
we're between 18 to 23 hours of
intermittent fasting okay this is where
we get into some serious fat burning we
get into something called a Toph eg a
Toph Ajit is a condition where your
cells are recycling old and damaged
parts it's cleaning of bacteria fungus
candida and mold so it's like a
self-cleaning action and your skin's
going to start looking better it's going
to be neuroprotective of your brain
you're gonna actually have better memory
better a mood better cardiovascular
function and you're gonna save a lot of
money because you're no longer consuming
three meals a day or six meals a day
you're doing two or even one meal a day
so you'll say between 300 to 600 dollars
a month so you're welcome
so now you can see the big idea and the
huge benefits that can occur these
things may not even happen to you but I
want you just to realize if they do
there's a solution you've got to keep
pushing through it until you get over
here alright thanks for watching
hi guys listen I want to thank you so
much for your wonderful comments and I
want to ask you if you wouldn't mind
giving me your review on Google I put a
link down below I'd really appreciate it
and thank you in advance